today we're talking about how from
software's next game is almost done
assassin's creed horses have a twisted
secret and more
in an interview with 4gamer from
software's hidetaka miyazaki mentioned
that an unannounced project is in the
final stages of development and that he
intends to continue focusing on
directing games one such future project
by the elden ring director was described
as a more abstract fantasy that uses
ideas that don't quite fall into the
usual souls-like adventure template
adding to this from software is also
hiring from multiple new games as the
company tweeted a link to a new
recruitment site that includes listings
for several positions back in january
rumors began to spread about the revival
of the studio's sci-fi series armored
core after alleged screenshots of the
game surfaced alongside gameplay details
of three-dimensional and dynamic action
but regardless of what's being worked on
eldon ring will still continue to
receive support in the future although
miyazaki mentioned that he wasn't ready
to reveal what fans could expect to see
next and our next story feels like it
belongs to the creepy vibes of the elder
ring universe like most sandbox games
2007's assassin's creed gave you access
to a horse that could help you get
around the map more quickly what you
might not know though is that altair
steed was in fact a human skeleton that
ubisoft engineers had stretched out and
transformed into a horse due to the
developers tools only supporting bipedal
characters former ubisoft developer
charles randall tweeted quote the horse
in ac1 was just a twisted effed up human
skeleton because our tool chain only
worked with biped in 3ds max randall
also shared a few other non-nightmare
fuel stories from the development of
assassin's creed for the character of
malek who only had one arm ubisoft
didn't have the budget for the custom
skeleton so the solution was to turn his
extra limb inside out and push it into
his abdomen randall tweeted quote i
assume if you could get the camera to
clip into him you'd see a tiny little
scrunched up arm inside the bicep super
weird but the devs did a awesome job
with both situations because i had no
idea now switching gears to some halo
news 343 industries has confirmed that
it is exploring the idea of adding micro
transactions to halo the master chief
collection in an update on waypoint site
community writer alex wakeford explained
that 343 will be renaming season points
as spartan points and is looking into
adding a new form of microtransactions
the new system is described as being an
optional additive alternative for
players and is being designed as a way
for people to either skip the grind of
obtaining new items or be given the
option to purchase the new ones that
they want the existing method of earning
points by leveling up and completing
challenges would remain in place beyond
that new features such as functionality
further mod support campaign
collectibles across all games the steam
workshop modding upload and download
tool new customization options and
quality of life improvements are also
being worked on for the game but alright
hit the comment section and let me know
what you're playing this weekend i'm
probably gonna play a lot of fall guys
and gas station simulator so let me know
what you're doing and i'll see you next
week